one of the stars of bob hart's abishola
every single monday night on
cbs at 8 30 p.m eastern including
tonight they're already in the midst of
season two one of our favorites
love this guy billy gardell back here on
the show how are you billy
hello sir and happy uh thanksgiving
weekend belated hope you had a great one
i did i did billy and uh you know when i
say you're
um you're one of my favorites it's not
just because
you and i have great chats uh when you
come on the show you know that billy
right
you know that right it's not just that
no i believe you rich
no i i believe you it's i feel the same
although
yes go ahead no it's because you're a
man with a big heart and it's not just
because your show has got a heart
in the title of the show billy uh you're
a man with a big heart
who uh also is uh you know
if i may say uh a regular viewer of this
show and you keep up on what goes on in
this program right billy
well i do rich and and you know what
does it take to to build a championship
team rich you got to count on the guy
next to you am i right you are correct
billy you are correct you you got to
have accountability and know that those
guys have your back
no matter what right that's right billy
that's what the steelers don't just
imagine this week when a couple weeks
ago on the show
brockman and michael got out got their
hands on some illuminati's pizzas
and they didn't even say anything to you
that's correct let me tell you something
that needs to be called out in the open
my buddy joey o'connell who i moved from
pittsburgh with 20 years ago in los
angeles we took whatever the car would
hold and came to la with two grand in
our pockets for one month's rent
and we have shared everything from a gas
station cheeseburger
to a five-star meal with mastros
and i have never once not told that man
what was going on in the food department
he has never done that to me either so
the two of you
need to look at yourselves because if
you want to go the distance
you got to have your bosses back that's
all i'm going to say on that
topic yep and uh you also
didn't mention our social media grand
maester tj jefferson
involved in that our call screener who
you spoke to uh
when uh you called in moments ago uh
adam chudwin
all of them all of them jackals there's
no other way
you know what you know what rich i would
be running two a days over there i would
keep those guys out of craft service for
a little while so they learn the lessons
and uh just so you punks know i sent
rich
a pack of six luminalities that are at
his house and i hope he doesn't share
any of them with you
wow is fact as a matter of fact don put
up the text that i screen grabbed and
sent
i go to the door there is a box of
pizzas because billy asked me for my
address about a few
days before i sent him a text did you
send pizzas he wrote back let me read
for the radio audience
those are the pies those heathens should
have shared with you
we will deal with those two properly
when i come on the show
next week and then a heart emoji because
like i
said you're all about heart and it's not
just because the heart emoji's in your
showtime
that's what's called full circle i look
at myself as a nice filler when you
can't get mcconaughey on
you know what i mean you're just as
handsome billy
you are what you're doing you know what
i look like i ate clark gable is what i
look like you know what you are billy
you're the deep dish version of
mcconaughey that's what you are that's
what i'm saying i am the dean
that's exactly right i'm the deep-dish
mcconaughey
yes you are billy yes you are and
i i i greatly appreciate your friendship
your
concern your respect um
and yeah let's tighten it up there boys
let's tighten it up a little bit all
right
let's look out for our quarterback
thank you thank you 10-0 william
10-0 your team is 10-0 and no
no we're assuming 11-0 is right around
the corner as well
how does that feel well i kind of feel
like uh baltimore has become a little
predictable
this year and i think people are kind of
catching their number and i hope they
stay that way through this week because
nothing i i gotta tell you watching four
three and seven teams on thanksgiving
was very twenty twenty
that was right on brand for 2020 yes
and uh and i'm really i'm i the the the
beginning of the true christmas
season for me would be dashing
baltimore's hopes
so let's just rip the band-aid off and
send them home for the holidays because
that
that's what we know is going to happen
but that's inevitable you know and
i know look um big ben was
somewhat of a question mark coming into
the season because of his injury and how
he missed last year and his advancing
age
but when i say how does it feel to be
10-0 on the version of 11 or all like
this didn't even happen
during the steel curtain error billy
this is like a first for
no never they never got i think eight no
was that was the
furthest they'd ever gotten uh
undefeated um
this is tremendous and um you know it's
it's one of those teams though
uh that you know what the the defense is
the difference
the the the advent of the dear ben
coming back and and
having that cannon at full power nobody
knew that was gonna happen that was an
incredible treat
the young receiver stepping up uh
johnson and
uh and uh clay paul this kid clay paul i
love him i
can we can get him downfield enough as
far as i'm concerned
but the defense man the defense and the
special teams ray ray mcleod
and and and i gotta tell you since that
trade we made for
minka fitzpatrick oh yeah was the best
in the world because
that part of the field is where we used
to get scorched
i mean brady would tell us he'd love i
love covert
i love zone i love zone and he would
torch us
in that area and i believe minka has
taken that away and because he's taken
that away
that pass rushes has has intensified the
steelers have always lived on
linebackers and when you're lying back
in court
strong enough you can kind of hide the
holes in the secondary and for a while
we didn't have all those engines in
there but now man
these guys are on their horses and
they're ready to go walk into it
and i even love the guys that are
stepping up spelling he's on the case
that's what i did you saw it
and i just feel like we have a very
special group right now it's
you know that feeling when you watch
your team long enough you go hold on
hold on something's cooking and i just
uh the only two teams i see
now that steelers in the past we've been
notorious to playing down and losing a
game we shouldn't have but i think
they're different this year that way but
the the two teams that that worry me
a little bit the rest of the way is
buffalo because i think they're heating
up again
and uh and i'm just i'm not i'm i'm very
i'm very wary of indianapolis's defense
i think it's better than a lot of people
give them credit for and uh those are
the two teams that
that might have a shot at ruining us
running the table but but like i said
we're just worried about
getting baltimore and making sure we
send them home miserable
this week that's that's all we're hoping
for right now billy gardell here on the
rich eisen show and we'll talk about bob
hart's abishola in a second again uh
season two continues tonight on cbs
every monday as it does
at 8 30 p.m eastern time i'm looking at
the schedule here you got indianapolis
in pittsburgh though so i and again i
know that we're not talking about
uh fans and craziness and waving towels
but there is still that temperature in
the confluence that
uh is unique to your stadium um the
buffalo one i'm i i don't blame you man
i mean that
is gonna be a great game it's a sunday
nighter the whole country it's
at western new york it's just up the
road
it's just great i love josh allen versus
big ben it's just
it's just going to be one of those donny
brooks but i do think there's a real
shot at 16-0 man
i really do and and then the question
about
that lurks essentially is the the the
one team that the football god
schedulers did not see fit
to put on the schedule and that's kansas
city um
you you got to be genuinely concerned
about that being down the road
i imagine billy well especially after
watching
mahomes and he'll go off like they did
that's the thing thing with that team
there's you you gotta get up on them
early
and you gotta get you gotta keep on the
gas as long as you can because that's
the kind of team where it's just all of
a sudden it's a waterfall
you're up by thirteen and then they
score 24
unanswered so i think getting off on
them early
is the key i i think you got to give up
some coverage to put a spy on the homes
but i
i don't know i think the raiders have
played them a couple times tough this
year they seem to
have a semblance of the defense form but
the dangerous thing is at any minute
it's just raining touchdowns with that
team so yeah that team
definitely worries me and i'll tell you
who else i'll tell you who else nobody
wants to play
is tennessee no one wants to see
that that that truck of a man henry
running at them
especially if he gets up into the second
level oh my goodness i i
i just he reminds me so much of jerome
bettis
it it's you can just see the defense get
deflated when there's five minutes left
on the field becomes trot not you just
know
you're in for a five minute beating
before you might get the ball back yeah
that's the reason just devastating and i
think tennessee is
i gotta tell you because and that's
another team that the way you beat them
is you gotta get off early again that's
how we beat them
because if you get off early then hannah
hill looks like he did when he played
for the dolphins
but if they're grinding man that's it
that's a team i don't think
anybody wants to see in the playoffs
yeah that would be a rematch again of
that that that game in which uh
tennessee came storming back and
you know big ben watching gustowski miss
at the end it was just like okay we'll
take that i mean didn't see that one
commenting yeah
well you'll take it man because again i
love you billy gardel i'm going to give
you your dream scenario you ready for
the stream scenario here's a dream
scenario
for you steve for you mr pittsburgh
steeler for all the steelers fans
afc championship game you welcome
le'veon bell into your house you beat
him
then you go to the super bowl and you
see antonio brown in tampa
where we all know san antonio holmes
once dotted the eye for big ben
who didn't get the mvp that that game
but you go to tampa
against antonio brown and you beat them
and big ben
does get his super bowl mvp and you
hoist the lombardi in 2020. how about
that that's your dream scenario right
there right
that's it i'm i'm fine with all that i
love all that and if the patriots
you know they're gonna miss they're
going to miss the playoffs as well so
that's just
your joy for all with the holiday season
but you beat brady and antonio brown
in the place where santonio holmes
dotted the eye but even with all that
ben didn't get the mvp you do that
but you got to beat le'veon bell first
in your own house your thoughts
and then i i think that would be perfect
and then i hope nfl films will hire me
to narrate that and instead of that deep
sentimental voice i'll just do it as he
enter
and then we couldn't believe it we got
time into the end zone and we blew brady
out
i would pay for that i would pay for you
to do
a yinzer voice over a steelers
championship reel
i would totally buy that america's game
stealers for coming in riding an
undefeated season and that ain't easy in
that you know
what who who came on and said that the
old joke is
how many pittsburgh steelers fans does
it take to fix like what a light bulb
like it's it's one to screw it in in
three to talk about the great steel
curtain days who told us that joke
somebody told us that that's funny i
don't know
it has to probably be choked i forget
somebody
how many steelers fans would take to fix
a light bulb want to screw it in three
to talk about the great steel curtain
days while they do it that that's the
one that i heard
recently oh gosh all right so i i see
nothing wrong with that
i do that when i'm at the grocery store
fantastic i remember a couple years ago
i was at the grocery store out here
before super bowl it was
one where we were playing seattle and we
were at the i was at the checkout
there's a guy behind me in a seattle
uh shirt and they had he had some
balloons
he had some seattle balloons he bought
at the grocery store
terrorize it you know why you wait four
hours those will be on sale
how'd that would go with that 12. how'd
it go with that 12. did it go around
i'm not sure they'd get the east coast
schumer out here
they do not but hey the good thing is
though is billy we can cut people off in
traffic because we're east coasters and
everybody else is here laid back that's
what you give the way get that exactly
everybody everybody out here in l.a
lines up to get off uh
in the same lane in an exit and you
could just just go just right in front
of it because that's the way we drive
uh bob hart's abishola sir season two
this is a
a funny show at a good heart and you're
the perfect guy to to make this thing
work you must be loving this
you must be loving it but billy uh rich
i'm beyond grateful i mean usually you
know you get on a hit sitcom that's a
one in a million shot and then they give
you another chance and by episode four
you're canceled and you're doing
infomercials
so to be in the mix again i am
beyond beyond grateful and i think it's
a sweet show as a sweet message
and of course it's written by chuck
glory i mean and al higgins and
so it's it's the it's it's like working
for the yankees man i'm
incredibly credibly grateful and and
it's been getting good reviews and good
ratings and got willing
we'll let this one run for five or six
years as well i'll give you the floor on
what you what the message is
uh for those who uh might be new to your
show and why they should watch it
billy go for it yeah bob hart's up
show bob is a guy's a midwestern guy
owns a compression socks
uh factory and he has a heart attack
from the stress of the business and
taking care of his family and he wakes
up in the hospital
and he meets this nurse who is from
nigeria and she is here as a
hard-working immigrant in this country
trying to make a better life for her
son and her family and the commonality
that they share is they both take care
of their families and
she has a lot of strength in stoicism
and bob is a hard worker but he knows
how to have fun and
they kind of give each other what they
don't have in the message of this show
is
if you're lucky enough to fall in love
doesn't matter what that person looks
like doesn't matter what size
shape color love wins the day
it's the most powerful weapon we have
and it's the last one we reach for so
i'm very proud of this show man i think
if you give us a couple shots
you'll be hooked now you're and and
obviously uh many people have
billy uh but it's got a great message i
just wanted to give you the
the uh the stage here if you will uh to
to deliver thank you my man
uh and thanks for the call and most
importantly thanks for for being a
friend
you know uh i don't mean it'll go all
golden girls theme on you right here but
thanks for being a friend
and you know um i i feel that you're out
there for me
uh billy uh even when i don't know that
you're out there watching and and uh
i appreciate the pizzas right i really i
remember i'm not just well not
interested in the show just when i'm on
it i'm watching
you hear that brockman that michael i
hear you
and i'm listening here's what i'm gonna
have to deal with when you hang up billy
is brockman
is what he says is an innocent bystander
in all this
the pizza acquisition was not his idea
it was not his idea he was just there
but he didn't he didn't
think it no no tj you're the only one
who said at some point
like hey what about rich should we lose
me right and then and then
for me to find out that it happened and
then i found out the excess amounts of
pizza that were acquired because of how
cheap they are they got it to get a deal
so that
they got 12 pies for crying out loud
a dozen they egged me on to get them oh
so it wasn't like it was my idea
mike you started talking about it over
there kelly they're trying to just know
here's the problem here's the problems i
want this to be
returned but they listen rich i want you
to know that i have
i've written some letters yes and we're
going to have a uh
we're going to have a committee put
together and we're going to look into
this and we're going to get to the
bottom of who's responsible for what
because
you know if we let this go who knows
what this leads to in the future we
don't want to set a precedent
or or how about this let's reverse
engineer it uh billy
let's let's have them come up with
various foods that i like so much that
they
refuse to include me on and then i find
out on live television that i can get in
copious amounts because people feel bad
for me
so why don't you guys try and get some
from any brothers together uh a carlos
bakery from cake boss for dessert talk
about getting that don't get i mean
and then we start getting it in copious
amounts here we can gain the system
rich i'm going to ask billy if you're
saying and i'll have some of that
vinegar slaw sent right to the house
could billy send some original oyster
house fish sandwiches from
from stations from market square you
know the oyster house now see you're
starting i'm starting to warm up to you
again
that's my favorite fish sandwich billy
if you could send some of those that'd
be great
your best right talking this morning
friday that was it
you take care of yourself billy let's uh
let's chat again soon okay
listen much love to all you guys and uh
love to your
families and be safe in the holidays
take it a day at a time
and we're going to get through all this
man god bless you guys same to you
that's billy gardel
great human great actor great uh great
great person great fan
big big big fan at billy gardel on
twitter
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here